the legend was true
he's here
black adam what have your powers ever given to you
nothing but heartache
i was a slave until i died
then i was reborn a god
my son sacrificed his life to save me
they're heroes
well i do
my vision has shown me the future you have two
choices you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be its savior
that's up to you
behind you
did he just catch a rocket
Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
black adam trailer video they're coming to comic
con there's a whole bunch of news so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos thor love
and thunder is also out in theaters this weekend
so i will be posting my post credit scene video
full breakdown easter eggs for the movie really
soon too be sure to go see the movie as soon
as possible this is a video that he posted of
him also doing his rock style wrestling intro
for black adam just trying to hype everyone up
for comic-con the most electrifying man in all of
the dc universe is coming to town so he thought i
was going one way with the rock but i went this
way with black adam they're both the same men
finally the man in black comes home to comic-con
let's go i'll see you then we smell what the
rock is cooking another really big comic-con
trailer but the big thing with black adams they
just confirmed that they're coming to comic
con they're going to be showing off another
even bigger comic-con trailer and a lot of you've
also been asking about black adam versus superman
because there was some recent news about them
actually doing a version of superman during the
movie not quite what you expect but superman
still being in the movie i wouldn't confirm it
the fulfillment of all of our fan wish dreams but
i think that they're trying to tease a much bigger
black adam versus superman movie in the future
like black adam 2 will be like a full on black
adam versus superman movie because the other big
thing they're obviously trying to set up is black
adam versus shazam but that's going to happen
probably in the shazam sequels the way that
zachary levi talked about it shazam 2 which is
actually going to be happening at the end of this
year we wanted to wait that long to get that movie
that'd be a completely separate plot but at the
end of that movie they'll also tease shazam versus
black adam the whole thing with this first black
adam movie is that they just want to establish him
inside the dceu this is taking place on the main
justice league earth even though we have the flash
movie they're doing all this multiverse stuff
doing it they're introducing all these multiverse
characters changing the timeline with the version
of flashpoint they haven't clarified where the
black adam movie takes place in the timeline
relative to the flash movie but i'm assuming that
it takes place before the flash movie just because
of the way they're airing the films but because
of that big superman cameo the way they used the
justice league at the end of that film even though
it was a faceless superman cameo there were all
kinds of memes that the director himself posted
about that too with henry capul's face on his body
even though they did things in that weird way
at the end of that movie that's meant to tell
you that it takes place on the same justice league
earth so during the comic con trailer when they're
saying oh the legends are true and then a separate
scene of someone saying oh he's here i believe
that's meant to tie in with the whole conduct
plot with inter-gang trying to take over the area
looking for the crown of sabach who's supposed
to be the actual main villain of the film like
how do you make black adam seem like a hero will
you put someone even worse in his film so that he
feels like more of an anti-hero that's why they
have all those scenes with hawkman trying to get
him to chill out like hawkman is probably one
of the most brutal characters to ever be on the
justice league he has a problem with killing foes
that's why you have a character as hardcore as him
talking to someone like black adam saying dude
you need to chill out stop killing so many people
even though sabacc is the main villain i believe
intergang is going to be this villain organization
an inner gang in the comics is sort of like an
intergalactic criminal organization like there are
many different evil organizations on earth during
the justice league movie they tease the injustice
league like that was the group that lex luthor was
trying to put together intergang is also a group
that lex luthor's involved with but that's just
because he's a really big villain in the dc he's
involved with many of the different big villain
organizations the reason why they're using inner
gang instead of the injustice society i believe
is just because black adam has more ties to inner
gang in the comics and that's also why they're
leaning on the justice society instead of the
justice league but obviously like i said there is
supposed to be a superman cameo scene at the end
of the film but the big report is they're actually
doing the same thing that they did during the
shazam movie with superman so if you remember at
the end of that film they basically had a faceless
cameo so even though it was meant to be henry
cavill superman like everybody was like oh it's
henry cavill because it's his suit you didn't see
his face and the director did clarify that there
were a number of reasons for that mostly for
scheduling reasons but also probably they were
haggling on how much they were going to pay him
for that so the odds of them bringing back henry
cavill just shot way up because the new ceo said
oh superman is a huge priority for us like there's
a much better chance of them actually doing a
superman spin-off film now reportedly at the end
of the black adam film there's gonna be another
similar faceless superman henry cavill cameo scene
i mean it's henry cavill but it's faceless so it's
kind of not henry cavill i'm sure there's going
to be all kinds of memes just like there were
after the first shazam movie it's one of those
situations where you're kind of excited but you'd
be bummed out if they didn't fully pay that off
in the future like okay i will take your faceless
superman cameo but you better give me a black adam
versus superman movie after this otherwise
i'm gonna be really pissed but like i said
sabach character meant to be the main villain he's
meant to be similar to the shazam gods that give
the shazam characters powers so like the shazam
acronym means different things for different gods
depending on which character you're talking about
if you're talking about the billy batson shazam
character or if you're talking about the teth
adam black adam character they basically have the
exact same powers they're just granted powers from
slightly different gods if you go back far enough
in the comics the wizard shazam and the council
of wizards at any given time in history have
basically granted powers to a champion in present
day that's meant to be the shazam character and
then he shares that power with the shazamly they
kind of teased black adam's comic book origin
story they've changed it a couple times in the
comics but the new 52 version i believe is the
one that they're turning more on what basically
happened is that black adam convinced another
family member like a young family member kind of
like billy batson during his era 5 000 years ago
to share the power with him and that's how he
got the power the movie backstory is a little
bit different and they're saying that his son died
to protect him and then he got the power of shazam
so it's a bit of a twist on that but it's kind of
the same idea they just want him to seem a little
more sympathetic like they're all these slave
masters that you see in the past hurting him
and his family it sounds like something happens
and he almost gets killed but his son winds up
saving him and they kill him instead and then if
you think about the backstory they gave you in the
first shazam movie then in a fit of revenge the
seven deadly sins are able to use that to free
themselves like they convinced black adam oh you
need to get revenge on all these people we'll help
you with that please free us and then the seven
deadly sins kill all the other wizards the rock of
eternity except for the wizard shazam but because
black adam is going off the rails his family's
just died and he's the one who freed the seven
deadly sins that's why he gets into the fight
with the wizard and the wizard winds up trapping
him for five thousand plus years so that's why in
present day you have the justice society hawkman
the doctor fake character basically telling
him he needs to chill out like there are bigger
problems that you need to help us with right now
and i believe it's all about inner gang trying to
use the crown of sabac in the powers of sabac to
basically take over the world slowly and i think
the whole idea with adriana tomas in this boy here
who's probably going to be her little brother or
maybe like her son or something like that is that
they'll be like surrogates for black adam's family
in the comics like he'll grow to care about them
and want to protect them and that's will convince
him to help the justice society stopped the forces
of inner gang in sabac i believe the way they use
the sabbat character it'll be the same thing as
the way they use the shazam and the black adam
characters like it'll be an avatar on earth that
sabacc will grant all his power to and just wind
up taking over that person so have a more humanoid
form during the movie but instead of characters
like black adam and characters like shazam or the
shazamly instead of sabach just granting his power
to another surrogate the inner gang is controlling
sabacc is going to like fully take over this
person as an avatar on earth and if it wasn't
clear black adam by himself is meant to be more
powerful than shazam when he's sharing his power
with the rest of the shazam lee that's the whole
idea is that the gods grant a finite amount of
their power to an avatar and that winds up being
shazam or black adam depending on which age you're
talking about so during the shazam movie shazam
winds up sharing the power equally amongst all of
his family members so when they all fight together
against black adam they're more equal but like if
it's just shazam versus black adam then black adam
is always going to be a little bit stronger that's
why you always see all those scenes of black adam
just wrecking all the different shazam characters
on their own because the only way they can usually
beat him is to fight him in a coordinated way or
use psychological attacks against him but what'll
happen is i'll do a brand new trailer video when
they drop this comic con trailer marvel is
also doing a really big comic-con panel this
year just like they did during 2019 there were
a couple years where marvel and dc just kind
of sat comic-con out like dc was doing their
version of dc fandom with all their trailers
i don't know if dc is still going to do another dc
fandom this year because they are bringing some of
their movies to comic con we probably won't find
out about that until later like they have a couple
big series that are airing next year like they're
working on the batman spin-off series on hbo
they're working on the green lantern hbo series
james gunn is currently making peacemaker season
two so like there are trailers that they can show
off later this year they have delayed the flash
movie for a little while yes there's all that
crazy stuff happening with ezra miller so when
we get more actual news more actual footage about
the flash movie i'll do a new video about that
don't worry i'm working on a video for the boys
finale that'll post next and then all my post
credit scene videos for thor easter egg videos
full breakdown of the movie will start posting
make sure you go see the movie as soon as possible
everyone click here for my full thor love and
thunder movie review video and click here for
my brand new loki season 2 first look video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!